.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Gut.
Ja. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Alexandra Baumann und
ihr Personal Trainer Steve Husistein.
Seit vier Jahren
holt er sie aus der Komfortzone.
Jetzt Gas geben und pusten.
Du kannst dich nachher erholen.
Gut, dranbleiben. Let's go.
Im Vergleich zu vor vier Jahren:
An welchem Punkt
steht Alexandra jetzt?
Schwierig zu beantworten.
Das kann ich nicht vergleichen.
Ich konnte anfangs z.B.
keine Übungen am Boden machen.
Sie kam nicht mehr hoch.
Oder? Hast du dich erschreckt?
Nein. Das war mitunter
eine meiner Motivationen:
Vor viereinhalb Jahren sass ich mit
meiner Patentochter auf dem Boden
und hatte das Gefühl,
ich brauche einen Kran,
um wieder aufstehen zu können.
Gut atmen.
Go, go, go. Wenige Sekunden.
140 kg wog Alexandra
in ihrer schwersten Zeit.
40 kg mehr als heute.
Stopp.
Übergewicht, Essstörung und Diäten
prägen ihr Leben seit Teenagertagen.
Wie ist das für sie?
Anstrengend.
Sehr anstrengend.
Man wird irgendwann auch sehr müde.
Irgendwann ...
... wünscht man sich,
dass es vorbei ist.
Dass es kein Thema mehr ist. Ja.
Diese Last
will Alexandra Baumann loswerden.
Leichter werden - v.a. im Kopf.
* Sanfte Musik *
Vor einem Monat
hat sie sich ein Velo gekauft.
Was für die meisten von uns
selbstverständlich ist,
kostete Alexandra viel Überwindung.
Ein Grund,
warum es so lange dauerte,
war schon, dass ich in mir drin
immer noch Hemmungen habe,
mit dem Körper, den ich habe,
in einen Veloladen zu gehen.
Ich fragte mich:
"Was denken die sich?"
"So eine Dicke, die denkt,
sie müsse ein Velo kaufen."
Ich hatte auch Angst,
mich zu blamieren.
Dass ich meine Beine
gar nicht über den Sattel bringe.
Das war wieder mal
eine Reflexion von dem,
was ich
immer noch oft über mich denke.
* Entspannte Musik *
Das war schon auch
ein bisschen ein Traum.
Wenn ich im Frühling mit dem Auto
an Rapsfeldern vorbeifahre,
stelle ich mir seit Jahren vor, wie
ich da mit dem Velo entlangfahre.
Jetzt kann ich das machen.
Das ist grossartig.
Alexandra Baumann.
43, Kommunikationsfachfrau,
seit zwei Jahren Single.
Klug und humorvoll erlebe ich sie.
Sie ist sich
auch andere Beschreibungen gewohnt:
Die Fette, die Eklige,
der Elefant, der Walfisch.
Fünf Jahre ist das her.
Ja ...
Das ist sehr konfrontierend,
wenn ich mich so sehe. Ja.
Alexandra
bewegt sich schon damals viel.
Sie nimmt an Stadtläufen teil
und trainiert.
Ihr Gewicht geht runter
und wieder rauf.
Mit schweren Folgen
für die Gesundheit:
Diabetes Typ 2,
Bluthochdruck, Gelenkprobleme.
An ihrem 40. Geburtstag
entscheidet sie sich
für eine Magenbypass-Operation.
In einem Blog macht Alexandra
ihre Geschichte öffentlich.
Das gibt Rückenwind.
Vor drei Jahren erreicht sie ihr
erstes grosses Ziel: die Rigi.
Ich glaubte sehr lange
selber nicht daran,
dass ich das schaffe.
Wenn man den richtigen Support hat,
wachsen einem Flügel.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Yeah!
Heute
ist sie nicht mehr so euphorisch.
Ich hatte
einen für mich schwierigen Winter.
Ich hörte sehr viel
meinen eigenen Gedanken zu.
Sie sagten, ich würde das Essen
eh nicht in den Griff kriegen.
Ich stehe heute an einem Punkt,
an dem ich weiss:
Ich will noch mal anders Gas geben.
Alexandra hat ein neues Ziel:
Das grösste dieses Jahr ist,
mal auf einen Klettersteig zu gehen.
Ja.
Ich habe sehr viel Respekt davor.
Klettern ist für mich der Horror.
Ich hasse es, wenn es wackelt.
Ich hasse es, keinen festen Boden
unter den Füssen zu haben.
Da sind sehr viele Elemente
des Unbehagens drin.
Warum tust du dir das an?
Ich will es mir beweisen
und mir zeigen, dass ich das kann.
Ja.
Et voilà.
Jetzt mit dem anderen Bein.
Noch mal.
Der grösste Schritt
ist im Mindset passiert.
Nicht nur mit dem Körper.
Dort ist viel passiert.
Bei der Kraft
und bei der Koordination.
Du machst Dinge,
von denen du nicht geträumt hast.
Egal, was an neuen Projekten kommt:
Das ist alles machbar.
Du hast gezeigt:
Wenn du willst, schaffst du es.
Ja. Deine Schulterblätter
hinten zusammennehmen.
Gut. Brust öffnen. Unten reinziehen.
Drehen. Drehen. Ja.
Und zurück.
Gut.
Ah, den musst du noch mal machen.
Der ganze Fuss klebt.
Aus der Ferse drücken.
Yes.
Mhm.
Gut. Du hast es gemerkt, oder?
- Ja.
220 Fr.
kostet eine Session bei Steve.
Hart zusammengespartes Geld.
"Allein hätte ich es nie geschafft",
sagt Alexandra.
Gut atmen. Das Ziel ist,
schnell runterzukommen.
Selbstbewusster sei sie geworden.
Wir lernen uns bei einer Reportage
zum Thema "Schönheit" kennen.
Es ist mir wichtig, auf einer
Plattform wie z.B. Instagram
auch mal
einen unperfekten Körper zu zeigen.
Wirklich mal etwas zu zeigen,
das noch in Arbeit ist.
Etwas, das diesem Schema,
das sonst auf der Plattform ist,
einfach nicht entspricht.
Alexandras starker Auftritt
löst viel aus -
auch
bei Musikerin Caroline Krattiger.
Ich schaltete einfach rein
und sah Alexandra.
Ich war sehr begeistert davon,
wie sie das macht.
Einfach ihr Auftreten
und auch ihr Durchhaltewille.
In der Folge
nimmt sich Caroline einen Coach,
trainiert
dreimal wöchentlich Kickboxen
und stellt die Ernährung radikal um.
Ich schaute eine Zeit lang
gar nicht mehr.
Ich ass, was ich wollte.
D.h.: einfach Fastfood.
Also, plus minus.
Zwei-, dreimal pro Woche McDonald's,
einen Döner ...
Oder in der Bäckerei
ein Sandwich kaufen.
Und ... Oder ...
Auch mal einen Salat,
aber leider blieb es nie dabei,
sondern es kam ein Berliner
oder eine Cremeschnitte dazu.
Das war mein Verderben.
Das Gewicht beeinträchtigte
auch ihre Arbeit als Musikerin.
Beim Unterrichten etwa
wurde längeres Stehen zum Problem.
Das habe sie zum Handeln gedrängt,
sagt Caroline, nicht ihr Äusseres.
In dem Umfeld,
in dem ich mich bewege ...
Ich mache Musik auf gutem Niveau,
seit ich klein bin.
Da ist das wie nicht wichtig.
Es zählt die Leistung.
Wenn du scheisse spielst,
aber super aussiehst,
bringt dir das nichts
auf einer KKL-Bühne.
Alexandra und Caroline
haben dasselbe Ziel:
Sie möchten ein Leben führen
mit weniger Einschränkungen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Auf diesem Weg
ist die Waage keine Hilfe.
Ich hatte immer eine Waage zu Hause.
Phasenweise hatte ich zwei
und stand auch dreimal
hintereinander auf beide drauf,
um das zu vergleichen.
- Okay.
Ich und die Waage - das ist eine
sehr obsessive, toxische Beziehung.
Warum hast du das verglichen?
Es könnte einen Unterschied machen,
wenn eine 200 g weniger anzeigt.
Rational nicht erklärbar.
Das war eine Besessenheit
mit einer Zahl, die ...
... wie ich jetzt merke ...
- ... nicht wichtig ist.
Nein.
- Ja.
Aber der Weg dahin,
dass die Zahl nicht wichtig ist ...
Ich bin immer noch auf diesem Weg.
Im Moment umgehe ich das,
indem ich nicht mehr draufstehe.
Aber jahrzehntelang hing die
Stimmung des ganzen Tages davon ab,
was die Zahl am Morgen
auf der Waage sagte.
Man ist einfach ...
Wie oft ich auf Social Media gefragt
werde: "Wie schwer bist du jetzt?"
"Wie viele Kilos sind es genau?"
Es zählt nur das.
Das war auch immer mein Grund dafür,
nicht anzufangen.
Ich fand: "Bis ich unter 100 bin,
muss ich 25 kg abnehmen."
Das ist schon ...
Das ist mehr, als ich bis jetzt
je abgenommen habe.
Ich habe
immer mal wieder abgenommen.
Dieser Gedanke: "Bis ich
unter 100 bin, sind es 25 kg."
Das war schon im Voraus ein Dämpfer.
Da denkt man sich: "Nein."
Caroline hat innerhalb eines Jahres
viel Gewicht verloren.
Die neue Bewegungsfreiheit
geniessen beide.
Heikler ist der Umgang mit dem Essen.
Ich war zu faul,
um ein Sandwich mitzunehmen.
Sicher?
Ich habe nur ein Stück Brot
und Fleisch.
Ich habe immerhin ...
Unsere Kochkünste.
Megalieblich.
Das Auge isst mit, oder?
Ja. Schön.
Ich liebe es, beim Essen ...
- ... gefilmt zu werden? Ich auch.
Mein Lieblings...
Vor fremden Leuten zu essen
und dabei gefilmt zu werden.
Das ist immer ein riesiges Thema.
Entspanntes Essen
findet bei mir selten statt,
wenn noch andere da sind.
Dass die Gesellschaft diktiert,
wie ein "guter" Körper zu sein hat,
ist für Alexandra ein No-Go.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass
nicht nur Fat Shaming nicht geht.
Body Shaming in alle Richtung
geht nicht.
Einer dünnen Person zu sagen
"Iss doch mal etwas!",
ist genau gleich übergriffig,
wie mir zu sagen "Iss weniger!".
Das geht beides nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
was die Motivation dahinter ist.
Body Positivity -
den eigenen Körper annehmen,
wie er ist, sei wichtig.
Aber die Gesundheit eben auch:
In den USA ist das ja ganz extrem.
Diese 250-kg-Menschen:
"Ich bin superhappy
und fühle mich superwohl."
Dann schaue ich auf meine 125 kg
und habe Probleme:
am Rücken, das fällt schwer,
man kann irgendwie ...
... die Beine kaum rasieren usw. ...
Dass man sich
dann noch wohlfühlt ...
... ist für mich schwer erklärbar.
Sich schön zu fühlen - okay.
Aber sich wohlzufühlen ...
Es ist doch offensichtlich,
dass man Einschränkungen hat.
Ich hatte auch immer das Gefühl ...
... bis an eine gewisse Grenze ...
Bei mir waren es 130 kg.
Ich fühlte mich ziemlich wohl
und auch beweglich.
Erst jetzt,
mit so viel weniger Gewicht,
merke ich,
was alles noch möglich ist.
Wie ist dein Körper jetzt?
Wie findest du ihn?
Ich finde ihn grossartig.
Er macht so viel mit.
Er ist megatapfer, kann sich
an neue Gegebenheiten anpassen ...
Ich staune immer wieder.
Ich klopfe mir manchmal
selber auf die Schulter.
Sieht vielleicht doof aus,
aber es funktioniert.
Genau.
Ich finde ihn grossartig
und bin ihm sehr dankbar dafür,
was er jetzt leistet.
Und ich glaube, das möchte ich
als meine Message durchgeben:
Jeder Körper darf grossartig sein.
Man darf jedem Körper die Chance
geben, grossartig sein zu können.
Ich finde nicht, dass
die Gesellschaft zu diktieren hat,
was grossartig ist. Einfach nicht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Noch drei Monate
bis zum Klettersteig.
Alexandra muss das Morgentraining
wegen einer Wadenzerrung
ruhig angehen.
Seit zehn Jahren
bewegt sie sich regelmässig.
Online gibt es dafür auch Häme.
"Die Dame behauptet,
Sport zu treiben."
"Ich muss mir wohl vorstellen,
dass sie ihre erhebliche Körpermasse
irgendwo 30 Min.
durch den Wald schleppt."
"Das ist zwar löblich und
bei dem Gewicht auch anstrengend,
führt aber sicher nicht
zu Gewichtsverlust
und verdient es kaum,
als Sport angesehen zu werden."
"Welcher Sport soll das sein? Wald-
spaziergang im Superschwergewicht?"
Ja.
Das ist jetzt vier Jahr her.
Das trifft aber immer noch.
Das ist halt so eine Wertung von ...
... etwas, auf das ich so stolz bin.
Für mich war das immer eine
Leistung, auf die ich stolz war.
Es war schwierig,
das durch solche Kommentare
nicht entwerten zu lassen.
* Meditative Klänge *
Ich sage jedem, der sowas sagt:
"Lass uns
zusammen im Wald spazieren gehen
und ziehen dir dafür
einen 60-kg-Rucksack an."
"Nach einer Stunde
reden wir dann noch mal darüber."
Ja.
* Meditative Klänge *
Wie wird man überhaupt so schwer?
Mit Mutter Esther blicken wir
in Alexandras Kindheit zurück.
Wir kämpften von klein auf
immer ein bisschen dagegen.
Ich denke,
das ist bei ihr genetisch bedingt.
Bei ihr schlug das immer sofort an.
Wenn ich Schokolade ass,
machte das nichts,
bei Alexandra aber dachte man,
man sähe es sofort.
Es war wirklich
schon immer ein Thema.
Es fing damit an,
dass ich nicht dieselben Kleider
wie andere anziehen konnte.
Oder nicht dieselben sportlichen
Aktivitäten machen konnte.
Die Hänseleien
fingen dann auch schon sehr früh an.
Sie tat mir auch immer leid.
Sie erzählte ja nicht immer alles,
was in der Schule
oder im Kindergarten passiert ist.
Ich dachte wohl,
ich müsse das selber bewältigen.
Und meine Strategie war, zu essen.
Gegessen hat Alexandra heimlich.
Ja.- Und wenn ich fragte,
wer die Chips geöffnet habe ...
Niemand.
- Ja.
Dort fing auch die Lügerei an.
Das stimmt.
Ich konnte nicht dazu stehen.
Ich schämte mich dafür,
das zu machen.
Ich konnte das
selber nicht nachvollziehen.
Mit der Esssucht kämpfe sie
bis heute, sagt Alexandra.
Keine Willensschwäche, sondern
eine Krankheit, genau wie Adipositas.
Noch sieben Wochen
bis zum Klettersteig.
Heute wird ihn Alexandra
zum ersten Mal besichtigen.
Coach Steve bereitet sie vor.
Morgen. Sali.
- Hoi.
Wie geht es?
- Gut.
Los. Dann kannst du erzählen.
- Ja.
Alexandra kämpft mit Problemen.
Meine Schulter
bereitet mir Kopfzerbrechen.
Jetzt tut sie gerade saumässig weh.
- Schon?
Nach der Wadenzerrung jetzt
auch noch die Schulter.
Genau. Langsam abstellen.
Seitenwechsel.
Auf den Stand konzentrieren.
Yes. Gut.
Sanft runter. Gut.
Ich kam an den Punkt, an dem mir
der Spassfaktor abhandenkam.
Okay.
- Auch beim Training.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich müsse jeden Tag etwas machen,
sonst schaffe ich das nicht.
Ich müsse mich perfekt ernähren,
perfekt trainieren ...
... perfekt mental ...
Jeden Tag, was weiss ich ...
So kann niemand leben.
- Also, hör zu.
Wir gehen 10 m.
Du konzentrierst dich aufs Atmen.
Und überlege: Wo ist dieser Druck
in deinem Körper?
Aber erst mal tief runteratmen
und 10 m gehen.
Ja ... Ja.
- Atmen.
Das ist jetzt dein Part.
Tief runteratmen.
Bleib tief,
Schwerpunkt in der Mitte.
Nicht Salsa tanzen oben. Da.
Tief. Und rennen.
Tschak-tschak-tschak.
Gut.
Das ist super.
Gesäss nach hinten.
Gut.
Lächeln, sonst sieht es brutal aus.
Geht, oder?
Es ist nur streng. Voilà.
Gut.
Nimm die Hände mit.
Mach oben auf. Atmen.
Es ist das erste Mal.
Wir werden einsteigen ...
Der einzige Ausstieg ist die Rega.
Ich frage noch,
aber ich kann ja nicht abbrechen.
Das streichen wir wieder.
- Du weisst, was ich meine.
Das macht mir schon ...
- Du machst einen grossen Schritt.
Du gehst nachher nach Engelberg
und siehst dir das von unten an.
Ja.
- Und dann stellst du dich hin
und siehst dir die Felswand
oder was dort ist mal an.
Dann fühlst du in dich rein:
"Was kommt da?"
* Sie lacht nervös. *
Alexandra tastet sich
an den Klettersteig heran.
Also, sie kriegt so einen Gurt.
- Ja.
Der Klettergurt
ist die erste Unsicherheit.
Ich habe mir wirklich überlegt,
ob ich in den Gurt reinpasse.
Wenn ich ihn
nicht über meinen Hintern bringe,
hat es sich erledigt.
Dann habe ich eine Ausrede,
warum ich es nicht mache.
Der Klettersteig läuft nicht davon.
- Hör auf damit.
Eine gute Ausrede. Oh Mann.
- Nein, passt.
Ja, dumm.
Das erste Hindernis überwunden -
aber das grössere kommt erst.
Ja, das müsste er sein.
Mein Puls ist schon fast auf 100,
wenn ich nur hochschaue.
Das ist nicht lustig.
Ach!
Aber ja ...
* Düstere Klänge *
Ich habe nicht damit gerechnet,
dass der Einstieg schon so ist.
Sonst hätte ich die Wanderschuhe
und Stöcke dabei.
Direkt ein Test, oder?
Falls ich nicht hochkomme,
muss ich es nicht versuchen.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ich glaube, das ist genug.
Ich muss gar nicht wirklich
auf den Steig.
Ein Klettersteig für Anfänger.
Nur eben ganz anders,
als sie es sich vorgestellt hat.
Nein. Nein. Nein. Nein.
Ich sehe
ein unüberwindbares Hindernis.
Eine dumme Idee.
Und der Gedanke:
"Ich muss mir das nicht antun."
Absolut doof.
Ich komme gar nicht in den Einstieg.
Nur über die Steine
da hochzumüssen ...
Das ist ... Nein.
Ich fühle mich nicht sicher.
Nein.
Alles sagt:
"Nein, nein, nein, nein."
Die Sprossen zu weit oben,
die Beine zu kurz.
Heisst die wirklich Höllensprosse?
- (Verzweifelt) Wer macht so etwas?
Als Einstieg? Höllen...
Das sollte doch motivieren.
Himmelssteig oder so.
Ach nein.
Ich spüre die körperliche Reaktion.
Ich könnte mich übergeben.
Es kommt richtig ... Wäh. Nein.
Wieso? Aus Angst?
- Ja, Angst.
Aus eigener Dummheit.
Ich müsste das ja nicht machen.
Es zwingt mich ja niemand.
Vielleicht ging ich
zu naiv an das Ganze ran.
"Das war's", denke ich mir,
als wir Alexandra ins Tal begleiten.
Diese Herausforderung
war eine Nummer zu gross.
* Düstere Klänge *
Einige Tage später
schickt mir Alexandra eine Nachricht,
die mich sehr überrascht.
Sie hat sich den Arm gebrochen -
beim Autoscooter-Fahren
an der Chilbi.
Aber die grosse Neuigkeit ist,
was sie kurz vorher gemacht hat:
Du hast mir das geschickt.
- Genau.
Du hast ...
... den Klettersteig mit Steve
gemacht.
Darf man gratulieren?
- Ja. Ich habe es geschafft.
Ja. Ja ... Ja.
Sie habe für sich entschieden,
es durchzuziehen -
aber ohne den Druck der Kamera.
Ich wusste immer, dass ich es
auf eine Art machen muss,
mit der es für mich persönlich
kein Scheitern ist.
Es war nicht das,
was wir abgemacht hatten.
Aber ich merkte,
dass das nötig war.
Das wurde mir
nach der Besichtigung klar.
Das ist die Höllensprosse.
Nur fünf Tage nach unserer
Besichtigung wagt sie es.
Coach Steve filmt mit dem Smartphone.
- Wunderbar.
Geh einen nach oben.
Dort hast du eine Pause. Voilà.
Locker bleiben.
- Ja, "locker bleiben" ...
Ja, er konnte das.
- Et voilà.
Enjoy. Schau mich mal an.
* Jauchzer *
Das Schwierigste war, nie zu wissen,
was noch alles kommt.
Das war echt übel. Zum Glück
gab es keine Ausstiegsmöglichkeit.
Ich wäre gerannt,
wenn das möglich gewesen wäre.
Du bist gerade da drübergeklettert.
- Jesus. Ich schaue lieber nicht.
Du darfst schon schauen,
woher du gekommen bist.
Schau zurück. Da drüber.
Halleluja.
- Wie fühlt es sich an?
Ich habe zittrige Beine,
aber wir haben es geschafft.
Noch nicht ganz.
Du kannst dich erholen.
Also, den Teil.
- Ja.
Das wartet.
- Das wartet jetzt noch.
Wir gingen eine Leiter hoch,
dem Fels entlang.
Das fand ich nicht so schlimm.
Ich war so überzeugt,
dass dort der Ausstieg ist.
Dann kommen noch mal drei Felsen.
Und ich: "Nein, hört auf."
3 Std. hatten wir, alles in allem.
Mit Zustieg usw.
Und angegeben ist inklusive Zustieg
1 Std. 10 Min.
Sei stolz und geniess es!
Hart trainiert
und die Angst überwunden:
Ziel erreicht.
Aber:
Es gab vielleicht drei Momente
von 300,
die wirklich Freude machten.
Das war der Moment,
in dem ich mich fragte:
"Warum machst du etwas,
das dir keinen Spass macht?"
Das ist so dumm.
- War es das falsche Ziel?
Das ist die Frage: Was ist
ein richtiges, sinnvolles Ziel?
Und ich glaube,
rückblickend ist meine Antwort:
etwas,
das das Herz zum Jubeln bringt.
Was das sein könnte, bleibt offen.
Einstweilen geniesst Alexandra
die trainingsfreie Zeit.
Sali. Küsschen?
- Wie du willst.
Zweieinhalb Monate später.
Alexandra Baumann auf dem Weg
zur Magenbypass-Jahreskontrolle.
Im Adipositas-Zentrum war sie schon
vor der Operation in Behandlung.
Auf die Waage stehen, bitte.
- Jawohl.
Das Gewicht musst du nicht filmen.
Sie können runter.
- Ja. 99,6 kg.
Wir sagen das.
Es triggert mich jedes Mal wieder.
Auf diesem Gewicht stehe
ich jetzt seit einem Jahr.
Das ist das,
was ich schwierig finde.
Kommen Sie rein.
- Jawohl, machen wir.
Okay. Wie geht es Ihnen?
Es geht mir gut. Ich fühle mich gut.
Der Gewichtsstillstand
beschäftigt mich einfach.
Ich meine,
Sie sind schon lange hier.
Der Teil hier ist
die sog. nicht-operative Therapie.
Das war der Gewichtserfolg
mit allen Anstrengungen:
Diät, Sport, Medikation.
Das ist,
was über die letzten drei Jahre
seit der Operation passiert ist.
Sie haben seit der Operation
40 kg verloren.
Der Vergleich mit Patienten,
die mit ähnlich hohem Übergewicht
operiert wurden, zeigt:
Alexandras Gewichtsverlust
liegt genau im Durchschnitt.
Sie sind in einem guten Bereich.
Sie haben einen vollen Erfolg
bei der Kontrolle des Diabetes
und Sie haben ein gutes,
normales Resultat beim Gewicht.
Wenn Sie nicht weiterkommen,
sind nicht Sie schuld.
Das ist das, was man
von dieser Behandlung erwarten darf,
wenn man alles richtig macht.
Macht man es falsch,
ist man wieder hier oben.
Es beruhigt mich teilweise
zu wissen,
dass ich
genau im statistischen Verlauf bin
und alles okay ist.
Genau. Für uns ist das ein gutes
Resultat mit diesen Massnahmen.
Aber für Sie ist es nicht genug.
So ist es.- Mhm.
Wenn Sie ausbrechen wollen ...
Sie wollen z.B. auf 80 kg runter.
Sie wissen, dass das möglich ist.
Aber wenn Sie ein Programm machen,
das Sie nächstes Jahr oder
in fünf Jahren nicht durchhalten,
müssen Sie nicht damit anfangen.
- Mhm.
Sie dürfen nur Massnahmen machen,
mit denen Sie
langfristig anständig leben können.
Das ist die harte Wahrheit:
Für Menschen wie Alexandra
bleibt das Gewicht trotz Magenbypass
eine lebenslange Herausforderung.
Immer die Frage:
Wann wäre ich mit mir zufrieden?
Das versuche ich
nun wirklich neu auszutarieren.
Wenn du auf das Jahr zurückschaust,
in dem wir dich begleitet haben:
Was für ein Jahr war da?
- Ein sehr herausforderndes.
Es lief gar nichts nach Plan.
Es war aber
auch eines der spannendsten.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich denke, ich werde das
wahrscheinlich nie los.
Da bin ich realistisch.
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich
einen inneren Frieden finde,
dass es so stimmt, wie es ist.
Und dass ich
stolzer darauf sein kann,
was ich erreicht habe und nicht
immer nur auf das fokussiere,
was noch möglich gewesen wäre.
Alexandra geht vorwärts:
Ein Buch hat sie in Angriff genommen
und sie macht
eine Coaching-Ausbildung,
um mit ihren Erfahrungen
andere zu unterstützen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022